tell you what uh sydney's been watching
recently she's been like she's gone off
the true crime for a bit
and she's just yeah she's now turned
over to uh trash tv
uh reality trash tv she's been watching
90 day fiance
bro i could just feel the script when
i'm watching that show
like you can tell like the producers
have made them do like two three takes
of course
[ __ ] it's awful i can't stand it i
watched like one whole season of it
and it was just like they just repeat
you watching one whole season i watched
i'm impressed yeah i don't know
i really don't know i didn't enjoy half
of it either i was watching it and it's
just like
they go in [ __ ] circles they'll be
like so they'll meet up and they'll be
like
yeah it's kind of weird but we just love
each other and then they'll just be like
red flags right from the start
yeah like yeah he asked me to paypal i'm
like 10 grand you know he doesn't want
to have kids i want to have kids
but you know i think love has a way and
it's like atheists like love drama right
because i i feel like watching 90 day
fiance right i lose brain cells watching
this
at least i was watching it but i think
it like i imagine what if it aired like
on twitch or something
i think it would be a [ __ ] excellent
experience if something like that aired
on twitch
huh like unscripted i mean just like
watching with like the twitch chat
you see all the reactions that's like
part of the fun fun thing the worst part
about watching it like in
seasons was like yeah without the
youtube comments 90 day fiance
is like 90 less enjoyable yeah because
the best comments are like
making sure that everyone agrees with
you who's the bigger [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah exactly it's it's like
literally like the
a real life version of ah am i the
[ __ ] you know it's
you know you you go that see the spicy
drama but watching it by yourself
i feel is just you you lose half the
enjoyment out of it how did you sit
through like a normal episode of that
oh it was hard because like i watched
because obviously like like every
anybody i got
into through the [ __ ] ed and rose
clips right that went around me too so i
was just like oh
you know if the clips are this good then
i'm pretty sure the entire episode is
good
it's hot well because like it's such a
drag it is it is one of those tv shows
where like the clip is the best way to
watch it yeah yeah yeah
watching this was like brutal like not
none of these couples are like good
people
they're all just like the worst people
yeah
doing the shittiest things to each other
and then being surprised when none of it
works
and it's like it is it is horrible i
mean i mean like it's trash tv but i
mean you know why you're watching it
right
no one's watching it to be like maybe
this situation will work out
and this girl's like you know this this
guy who's on his 10th marriage note and
i've only known for three months i don't
know if he really loves me
it is literally
someone has made like a playbook of like
the worst setups to relationships
like there's always like someone who
can't speak the other person's language
so they just can't communicate most of
the time
and it's like it's like what the [ __ ]
are you doing
[ __ ] melee we're recording
you're watching 90 day fiance he's just
loading up an episode right now
apparently so what are they talking
about
like there was like one where it was
like the girl's like 18 and the guy's 46
and has two kids and i'm like
that just sounds like a bad idea like ed
rose yeah it was like yeah it was like
that on someone else yeah
it was like um was the other one there
was like these this
was one of them i think it was like oh
he was like a south african guy
and the other one was like an american
like uh she was like super activist
and stuff and like he was just kind of
like the most laid-back man on earth was
like yeah yeah wherever wherever
and she was just like i need you to know
that i care about these things and she
was psychotic
and like watching her like behave around
this guy was like awful
it was and i was just like this is
terrible this is awful why is he doing
this how much is he getting paid
yeah that's what i'm wondering like it's
the plc like i need to know no no it's
tlc so they're definitely paying back
are you sure they're getting paid
they're getting paid pennies like
because
i feel like i hope they're getting paid
because if they're not getting paid
i don't know why they're putting up with
half of this [ __ ] yeah it is i'm pretty
sure tlc pays all of the people that
they have sure
but yeah but like i use the word paid
very loosely like they're probably
getting paid scraps for that [ __ ]
yeah it's just like it's like i'm
watching this and i'm like how much
would you have to pay me
because you know that uh you know the
rose the the filipino
girl she's like a youtuber now yeah i
sure sure
so it's just like you probably got paid
[ __ ] all but
hey you've got a youtube career now i
guess i don't know you have a funny
rap situation where if the other side is
just so
goddamn awful it makes you look amazing
yeah yeah yeah
and i edited her solid